president Trump owns a pretty decent
chunk of property in Florida and Dorien
could make landfall right around as you
just saw his mar-a-lago estate the
president has canceled a planning
planned overseas trip to track the storm
but he is still taking considerable
grief political sniping even before the
storm lands chief White House
correspondent John Roberts has that part
of the story tonight as Dorian continues
its relentless march toward the Florida
coast President Trump tweeting that the
federal government is fully prepared for
what lies ahead we're ready we have the
best people in the world ready and
they're gonna help you we're shipping
food we're shipping water but it may be
that you're going to evacuate we're
going to see what happens we're waiting
it does seem almost certain that it's
hitting dead center the president's
critics comparing his concern for
Florida with what they say was his lack
of it when the storm was taking direct
aim at Puerto Rico part of its that
Florida could be a swing state in 2020
and part of it as Florida is not an
island full of people of color
three days ago President Trump appeared
annoyed that Dorian was eyeballing
Puerto Rico tweeting Wow yet another big
storm heading to Puerto Rico will it
ever end following that up with Puerto
Rico was one of the most corrupt places
on earth at the same time FEMA was well
prepared for a direct hit on the island
having stocked multiple warehouses with
relief supplies but Democrats were
focused on what the president said not
what he did there's no doubt that the
president doesn't view Puerto Rico
as part of the United States he doesn't
view people who didn't vote for him as
important and he doesn't view people who
aren't white as important as everyone
else Democrats also criticized the
president for giving the green light to
diverting funds from one of FEMA's
disaster relief accounts to address the
crisis on the border
FEMA insists it still has plenty of
money to address storms and has already
mobilized that aggressive response to
durian but Florida's Democratic
agriculture commissioner nikki freed was
incensed in a statement saying the
president must be out of his mind if he
thinks it's a good idea to shift funds
out of feet
for immigrant detention at the border
while a potential category 3 hurricane
bears down on the United States Florida
is a critical state in president Trump's
reelection bid to be sure he also owns a
lot of property there but some of the
attacks against him appeared way out of
bounds
Canada's former prime minister Kim
Campbell who held office for four months
tweeting I'm rooting for a direct hit on
Mara Lago after she was pummeled online
for that tweet Campbell came back to say
I have deleted my tweet about the
hurricane and mar-a-lago and sincerely
apologized to all it offended it was
intended as sarcasm not a serious wish
of horror president Trump will be
spending tonight tomorrow and tomorrow
evening at Camp David he will be back on
Sunday for meetings with his national
security and FEMA team about the
hurricane with this category three storm
bearing down on Florida the president
really had no choice but to cancel his
visit to Poland he just said in the
South Lawn that he will schedule that
for a later date may pair it together
with a visit to Germany the president
also talks about the hurricane james
comey
China Iran and a whole lot more Brett so
stay tuned an impromptu marine one press
conference will air that two missing it
I know sorry John thank you